okay so wedding day isn't complete
without some glam we're talking all
things hair and makeup and i'm keeping
the dress on because i just can't part
ways with it yet so joining us today is
the owner of sparkles beauty bar stacy
bledsoe thank you so much for being here
stacy and fun fact stacy and her team at
sparkles are doing my hair and makeup
for the wedding and all of my
bridesmaids so i'm really excited to
talk about all of this and before we get
into everything we have a beautiful
model over here we're going to see a
finished look right tell us what's going
on yeah so we are doing
a soft glam look on her today so we
finished one eye and vienna's gonna
contour
and add a little add one more a lash to
her and a little sparkle
light glam so this is on trend to soft
glam a little bit of shimmer
not not a sparkle but a shimmer okay i
can't wait to see the the final product
here and as she's working away let's
talk through some of the different
options like you said a soft glam maybe
if you don't want over the top or a
natural look what's what's trending
right now so what's trending is our soft
glam and then we're doing also um a lot
of natural look okay so bohemian natural
and then also
smokey eyes oh okay i love that smokey
eye so you know that never goes out of
style so my biggest question is let's
say you do the smokey eye and a heavier
makeup look then should you go a little
softer on the hair so it balances out or
what do you recommend softer on the lips
probably when you have a smokey eye and
then yeah you don't want to be too much
so when the eyes you want to go softer
lips heavier eyes vice versa so it's all
about a balance sometimes i like to go
big or go home but it's okay to tone it
down a little bit and what i really love
about sparkles i'm taking advantage of
this service is if people can't make it
into the salon you guys offer mobile
services we come to you we have mobile
services
so like you were doing your glam squad
mobile at your event yes we're excited
we have 11 people total so you guys can
accommodate any size any amount of
people right correct and same goes with
different you know skin tone types and
hair types you can do it all we can do
it all yep and then we can uh we can put
lashes on like she's putting lashes on
right now um where she's putting on our
lash line this one's called stay up yes
you have a whole line of lashes and you
even have some fun ones right if you
want yeah
pink ones we have violet ones we're
getting in a holiday collection with
tinsel i love it see i'm all about
tinsel circle fun this is looking
beautiful over here and if people do
want to come into the salon where are
you located you have two locations we're
in downtown summerlin and we are in
henderson okay and just selfishly as a
final tip for a bride to be this weekend
what advice do you have going into a
wedding as i'm getting ready to get my
hair and makeup and wear a dress and do
everything well my advice would be make
sure you have some snacks
yes to snacks yes to snacks make sure
you're not like going into it hungry but
i think just have fun like savor every
moment it's gonna go by so quick
it's gonna go by quick but yeah just
have a good photographer
well and that's why i have a wedding
dress on right now
i'm extending the celebrations
throughout the week so as we finish up
here anything else that kind of pops
from her look what about the lips or a
little bit yeah we actually put a little
tom ford shimmer on her lips i love that
it's a gold shimmer and i don't want to
forget you have to do a trial right
before oh yes yeah
yeah we always recommend a trial so you
can be very picky we did a trial with
you what are you saying and you were you
were easy though you were easy yeah we
did do a trial make sure you get your
look down that you want and we can
always adjust yeah because sometimes you
see a photo and then you do it on
yourself you're like i don't look like
the photo but
well thank you stacy for breaking
everything down i'm so excited to have
your whole team join me this weekend and
we are excited we have to get a shot of
the final look over here she looks
absolutely beautiful so thank you to our
model and thank you to everyone at
sparkles